[Music]
well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what is
making the headlines with the political
editor of the daily mirror paper career
and the political editor of the sun
harry cole welcome to you with us until
just before midnight so to the front
pages then let's start with the
financial times leads on the uk widening
the booster jabs program to all adults
in the hope of beating the omicron
coronavirus variant
the metro front page also reports on the
expansion of the booster jabs rollout
the eye with a similar headline let's
take a look boosters for every adult it
says
and the mirror leads with similar words
new variant battle as the gap between
second and third doses cut to three
months rush jab they say
the guardian reports that ministers want
the nhs to return to distributing 500
000 vaccines a day
the daily telegraph has a picture of
president joe biden as it quotes him
saying there is no need for new covert
restrictions in the face of the omicron
variant as he said its emergence was not
a cause for panic
and the daily star reports despite
concerns around the new variant under
current rules school nativity plays can
still go ahead
quoting as you can see a well-known tv
drama so we're joined tonight by peppa
carrera and harry cole welcome to both
of you um so uh many of the newspapers
leading on this in fact i think that was
a clean sweep was it not and uh the
message from the government of course is
that uh they want the boosters to beat
this whatever harry this turns out to be
yes it's a by by some time a few
restrictions will come in to come into
force overnight masts on trains which my
train was anything to go by this morning
people have uh taken that into their own
hands before it becomes law at four a.m
tonight or where whatever it is and
travel restrictions coming in uh
overnight while the world scrambles to
work out whether this really is uh a
sort of vaccine-busting um menace of a
mutant whoever mutant coveted strain is
as some fear
or whether we might be slightly over
hyping this and um the government are
going to regardless of that use it as a
massive opportunity to drive that
booster campaign um there was a booster
announcement that was meant to be coming
today anyway before boris johnson's
shock um saturday night press conference
where he decided to break a habit of
his premiership so far and actually go
further and quicker and faster than
anyone expected to uh before he was sort
of forced dragging into it like we've
seen with previous um sort of covid
moves but um you know there's an
argument to be made also that the
government are very comfortable on this
terms after a rocky few weeks there's
nothing more actually than they'd they'd
love to be doing than banging the drum
for boosters and i think we'll be seeing
a lot of the pm tomorrow who's um
ordered the whip to be cracked again
well cracked once again
and uh get get get jabs in arms up to
sort of 500 000 a day three and a half
million a week in that way that we saw
earlier in the year um that's the peak
of the vaccine roll out i think we'll
see a sort of call to arms for a
national effort again tomorrow yes and
pippa do you share um harry's and i
don't know if i'm paraphrasing you
slight sense of skepticism here uh not
not to undermine the possibilities of
this variance certainly but you know
this is politically expedient on a
number of on a number of measures one it
it boots out stories of second second
jobs and and sleaze it brings in new
measures which maybe they wanted to do
to protect christmas and that idea of
really trying to get through the booster
program as quickly as possible you know
to save the winter and save the nhs
those are all good reasons why you might
want to be rather concerned about this
variant
well it's certainly more of a comfort
zone for the government isn't it they
have over the last couple of years
um had sort of a bumpy ride on
coronavirus until they got to the point
of the vaccine rolex and that is widely
regarded as a great success of the nhs
and the vaccines task force and so on so
um it's not a surprise that they're
happy to talk about it however
there was previously some concern in
government about
the amount of time it was it was taking
despite the fact that the booster
campaign was underway to get everybody
done so you know if this ends up just
being an opportunity to speed that up
and i don't think anybody is going to
complain too much um
that in itself though will present some
challenges because of course about 50 of
the mass vaccination centers which were
set up which we saw last year when the
vaccine relate began have been closed
since the spring and many gps who
administered
the jobs as well have gone back to their
day the day-to-day um
work with patients
um and also administering the the flu
jabs so stepping up the campaign putting
it on steroids and sajid javid
announced the comments today isn't
necessarily going to be um you know one
click of the fingers and then it's done
and then they also we're waiting to find
out um about who will get the jobs first
both the um with professor jonathan van
tam and sanji javid both said today that
the nhs would be announcing in the
coming days how that would work the
operations side of things but the
expectation is that it will sort of work
its way down the age cohorts as the much
as the original boosters did so you
don't end up in a position where a bunch
of healthy
year olds dash along and get all the
booster jabs leaving vulnerable 48 49
year olds um who are more vulnerable 48
49 year olds who haven't had yet yet had
their boosted jabs so there's a bit of
there's a bit still to come in terms of
what we're going to learn about the
booster campaign yes it's definitely
more comfortable territory for the
government um we don't as harry rightly
says yet know how serious obamacare is
going to be um we're not going to know
for a few weeks and until then i'm sure
there'll be lots of speculation
so daily telegraph um as we uh saw uh in
our papers list there no cause for panic
president joe biden saying that new
restrictions should not be necessary to
deal with omicron telegraph never a fan
of a restriction it brings me to a
question harry for you which is is it
difficult for readers to digest the news
on um the virus objectively because the
papers do have their own access to grind
don't they
i wouldn't say their access to grind but
i do think there is a sense of
inevitability about this as lots of
people sort of
our sort of post back was a little bit
full of but here we go again
um you know the the sort of
they the government always very
caveated in what they said about a
future lockdown and a great christmas
coming is always dependent on this
future you know on there not being a
mutual a mutation of a variant of
concern coming down the line and lo and
behold here it is three you know
three weeks before um you know people
have been moving around the country
making their plans so i think there's a
bit of grim
grim acceptance of it um but the problem
is is the science is so advanced now we
just don't know
um how bad this is going to be in fact
if you go back and listen and think
about how long it took for
the you know true effects of the
original virus um
to to be to be known how you know how
before the the alpha beta delta variance
kent brazil whatever we called them back
then um the problem is this is this is a
relatively new um phenomenon
and i don't think there has been really
time for anyone to make a clear decision
on it so i think there's mostly just
confusion about it in the fact that the
government doesn't seem to want to get
caught on the hot by it but really they
could well be growing back in a few days
once it becomes clear whether this is
really is the
variant that could could uh could you
know blow the whole vaccine roll out i
thought it was really interesting to
really do interesting things happen
today
one clive dix um who is the
forward chairman of the vaccine task
force popped up on the bbc and said you
know what actually i'm not concerned
about this at all i don't think this
will be the one i'd be almost impossible
for this variant to break the vaccine
didn't quite go with the narrative um
other people are pushing and the second
really interesting i thought things i
thought there was inevitability about it
all is the most vulnerable people in
society the ones with the with the
weakest immune systems are going to
start getting their fourth doses and
where the most weakened society have
started the whole vaccine rollout has
shown everyone else has followed so when
does this end do we do we have a booster
campaign forever now and uh you know
we'll be we'll we will be we'll just be
talking about the next jab you know in
in the future forever yeah that you're
right the ammunia compromised have had a
third primary jab which means they will
be eligible for a booster job which of
course is their fourth jab um guardian
and the financial times talking about
the booster rollout uh the guardian a
race to return to 500 000 uk jabs a day
uh i think the telegraph is pointing out
that about 25 million adults yet to have
their boosters are now eligible i mean
that's that's a job isn't it for the nhs
and the financial times as well pippa
booster jabs drive widen to all adults
in the battle to quell omicron um
we will see and we because there's a
delay in actually reporting these cases
uk rises uh to 11 the the financial
times said we are presuming that there
are many more cases in this country and
across europe i'm guessing pippa
yes that's right and i've spoken to
government officials today who think
that the number could be at least ten
times uh uh that meant that number um we
know if i think it was six in scotland
and two more today in england taking
english total two to five um but eleven
is is you know i think a very very very
conservative estimate it's of course
only those cases which have actually
been confirmed and um
slightly worrying um revelation from
john swinney the deputy first minister
in scotland this morning when those
cases were announced which was that they
as far as they could work out
their cases did not have
any recent travel history in southern
africa indicating that they were already
um they they basically picked it up from
the community and the community spread
was on was already underway and as we
know from coronavirus throughout you
know the original seeding of the virus
in the uk and subsequent um subsequent
variants that that
inevitably it revives a lot faster than
than you know we can pick up on it and
confirm it officially that's just the
way it works so it we know from south
africa that it's a very fast basic
spreading variant what is not yet clear
is um how uh how affected the vaccine
will be as we've said um and the key
metric which the government is using is
hospitalizations uh assadji javid told
mps today um and the problem with that
is that um you know this is there's a
lag between when people
get the uh get the virus in the first
place and then the symptoms develop and
then they might end up in hospital um so
you know the government said that the
they're going to be a place for
they're going to be reviewed in three
weeks time so before christmas they
certainly indicated before mps disappear
for the christmas break will that be
soon enough for them to be able to tell
how dangerous this particular virus is
and whether it can evade the vaccine i'm
not sure that it will so
you know they're making all the leaders
in all the different parts of the uk are
saying that it's not just about um that
these aren't just restrictions that
they're that they're precautions but i
think if they continue over christmas
and if indeed we need more the ft is one
of the papers that suggests that their
their planning is contingency for
working for home guidance over over
christmas um and that the
extension of face masks could um apply
to pubstone restaurants in england as
well because the moment obviously it's
it's just public transport and
um
and shops then you know we could see a
situation at christmas not in lockdown
but where there are um there are sort of
more restrictions on on
our lives until we have a clearer answer
um as to how dangerous omicron actually
is yes indeed we'll just whiz through
the last couple of papers we were going
to do daily mirror your paper pippa rush
jab the new variant battle and the daily
star jesus mary joseph and the wee
donkey
because as well as boosters for over 18s
uh second jab being offered to 12 to 15
year olds and now the question about
five to 12 year olds under active
consideration but for the moment the
school nativities can go ahead if it's
safe to do so in your schools
secure stammer pippa picked a rather
busy news day to have a a small rather
large reshuffle
well i think that was i think that was
initially the point that there was a lot
of sales going on um and uh as ever uh
labour in particular with all sorts of
suggestions that it's more concerned
about looking inwards and outwards it's
quite keen just to get on with it um but
it ended up being a very broad-ranging
reshuffle apart from angela rayner who's
the depth leader
future of workpost and
the shadow chancellor rachel reeves
almost every other post there's a couple
of others too but almost every other
post um was was changed and there was a
couple of sort of big hitters brought
either promoted or brought into the
shelter cabinet for the first time under
kyo steiner at summer vet cooper
obviously is the big name who um was
cabinet minister under gordon brown in
fact i think her first front bed bench
job um was as a health minister in the
late 90s under tony blair so she
certainly has a lot of experience to
offer and she's become quite well known
as a as a
labor figure and actually you look at
this new labour shadow cabinet and it
quite possibly has as many recognizable
names as the actual cabinet which uh for
opposition is quite impressive but um
but uh yvette cooper is event cooper is
well known um she's been you know around
firm she won't mind me saying this
around for a long time on the front
bench on the front line of politics and
uh it was felt that libra needed
somebody that was uh
possibly a bit punchier and could um
critique pretty detail to task hold that
thought because i mean we've got 30
seconds left and you should have seen
harry's face during that i have to say
but anyway very quickly very quickly
harry
i'm not sure they'll be uh i'm not sure
they'll be lining up in the streets to
recognize bridget phillips and uh and
people like that no that it is a
definitely a new broom for kier
um and also absolutely brutal drive-by
shooting on angela rainer this morning
the day of her big speech gives her five
minutes warning of the reshuffle sends
her out onto the airwaves all morning to
say there's not gonna be a reshuffle and
then um ugly humiliates her if only he
was that good at attacking the
government rather than his own side
secure might be making some headway